when I learned that akira toriyama
wanted to make this film partially
because of a personal vengeance against
Dragonball Evolution I knew everything
was right in the world Dragon Ball Z
battle of gods is a new anime film from
series creator Akira Toriyama the
creator of the Dragon Ball and Dragon
Ball Z manga this was released
simultaneously in theaters across the
nation tonight for one time only and I
got to experience it with a packed
theater full of people that I completely
understand now if you guys didn't know I
grew up watching Dragonball Z it really
is the first anime that ever made me
inspired to watch other animes because
it was one of the first ones that ever
broke through to the mainstream and
really captivated people in the late 90s
not just kids like my dad watched it
with me too it really actually had a lot
of effect on people of all different
ages and a lot of times you guys do ask
me Chris what is your all-time favorite
movie I don't have one guys I can't pick
a favorite I can't even pick an order of
favorites that's just not how my brain
works I do however have a least favorite
movie of all time and if you didn't know
it is Dragonball Evolution the American
remake the attempt at tried to recreate
Dragonball Z for American audiences and
all they really did was rape it I mean
it was horrible
it was awful now if I were you and I was
not a Dragonball Z fan I would be
watching myself right now going this guy
is so biased he grew up with that thing
of course he's gonna like it he's not
gonna have any problems with it he's
completely biased this review isn't even
fair and I understand how you might
think that but let me give you a bit of
an analogy I also grew up watching the
original Star Wars trilogy and I love
them but I also watch the Star Wars
prequels and I experienced those and I
know that they just weren't what most of
us wanted them to be I grew up watching
Dragonball in Dragon Ball Z and I do
love them but I also experience
Dragonball Evolution so I know what it's
like to experience something Dragonball
related that's totally so I did go
into this film with that era of
skepticism knowing that I have
experienced crappy dragon ball before
and I have in no way ever hidden my
thoughts on it DBZ battle of gods is
exactly what I wanted as a fan of Dragon
Ball Z because it combines the best
elements of Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball
Z it has the
really awesome an epic action that was
in Dragonball Z but it has the fantastic
humor that was ever present in
Dragonball and that was something that
really surprised me this is by far the
funniest Dragon Ball movie we've had it
really is very funny and clever and I
was laughing throughout the entire film
one of the things I loved was the fact
that they actually infused the villain
beerus the god of destruction with humor
himself he wasn't like some evil epic
guy who just went around killing
children
he was just somebody who slept for 50
years woke up and they thought what can
I do today well I'll just find some
planet to flick away into nothingness
but he just goes to earth looking for
food because he loves trying different
delicacies I love that because that is
so Akira Toriyama he takes a villain
that you expect to be a certain way and
then just turns all the cliches on their
heads another cool thing about beerus
that my very clever fiance actually
mentioned is that he looks very inspired
by certain Egyptian gods particularly
Anubis and segments and he took all that
and made a really cool villain and a
movie is really only as good as its
villain and I really liked beerus in
this film all the characters live up to
the way they were in the original series
but one of the things i loved again was
the humor especially with Vegeta's
character they found such the perfect
note to have been jito try to be a
badass but he's also kind of become more
lighthearted and he also knows who
beerus is and how powerful he is and so
he's always trying to distract him from
destroying the earth and all these
hilarious ways and I dug it it was
hilarious
but if you're a fan of DBZ you know that
there are certain moments throughout the
show that stand out as big moments you
know those clips on YouTube with tons of
views Vegeta's final flash against cel
Goku's 20 times kamehameha against
Frieza you know these big moments that
you want to watch over and over again
this movie has a few of those that I
will not spoil it for you and that was
something that I really loved because
they understand certain things that fans
expect to see and they deliver it as for
problems that I have with the film I can
tell you this is not a standalone film
if you haven't watched Dragon Ball Z
prior to this or any of the other films
you're gonna be lost this is a film that
expects you to know where all the
characters are where they've been who
they're related to who they're dating
bla bla bla you can't really just walk
into this movie because you won't
understand it also there is a side story
involving a character that was in Dragon
Ball quite often that I won't spoil for
you and I didn't really feel it was
necessary to the film and some might say
there wasn't quite enough fighting even
though there was
humongously epic moments of Awesomeness
with really beautiful animation that was
definitely the most stunning animation
work I have seen in a Dragonball Z film
or the series it's a great combination
of hand-drawn animation with digital
animation but I can see a fan who just
wants to watch a Goku punch things being
disappointed by the fact that there
isn't a humongous fight until about
halfway through the film I however just
love these characters so much and love
seeing the tiny nuances between them and
they really did a great job of pulling
that off I'm so happy that Akira
Toriyama came back was involved in this
project and announced that he wants to
make more there's gonna be more of these
coming out and I can't wait to see them
I'm gonna give this film two different
ratings if you are a fan of DBZ this is
an a I love this movie you're gonna
enjoy it I had a lot of fun with it if
you're a casual viewer of anime this is
more along lines of a B if you weren't
really that into Dragon Ball Z if you're
not into Dragon Ball Z at all don't even
see this movie because it's not made for
you it's more made for fans of the show
who really wanted something else besides
what we got back in 2009 I love this
movie guys and I hope you do check it
out if you're fans there are a few more
showings over the next few days and I'm
sure the Funimation will release the
blu-ray soon speaking of Funimation I
would like to announce I've actually
become partnered with them they're
sending me some of their anime releases
for me to review on this channel and to
promote and I think that is so awesome
of them for one they recently sent me
psycho-pass Volume one and two I'm
really interested in seeing this show
and I can't wait to check it out and
review it for you guys they also sent me
Dragon Ball Z season five season six is
coming out very soon in fact it comes
out today August 5th I'm gonna be
picking that up soon as well I hope you
guys do check out some of fun dimensions
releases they have a lot of great stuff
I am extremely excited to be working
with them I just returned from LA like
the other day literally I slept for like
11 hours I've been editing my interviews
with Sean being Ali Larter and Morris
Chestnut I'm extremely excited to share
those with you guys thank you so much
for watching and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
you
[Music]